Hi, I'm Chad Walquist. I'm an architect at
Palunteer. Today I have Bennett who leads a
lot of our work on observability especially in the
AI space which requires kind of new tool sets. So
thanks for joining me Bennett. Thanks for having
me. So observability and kind of AI and what
does that mean to you? Like maybe just give us a
little bit of a peek into your world. Sure. So,
if I'm building a complex workflow on top of
myontology and my LLMs, um, it's going to cut
across many different resources that I build on
top of my ontology. Uh, and I'm going to want
to see tracing and request history and logging
across all these different products. Um, and I'm
gonna want a bird's eye view. And I'm gonna want
to drill down and see specific execution, specific
logs, specific error messages, and drill down to
see what is going on in my complex workflows. Uh,
either if I'm the one triggering them or if an
automation or an agent is the one triggering
them. Um, and so, um, every invocation, every
log line, um, I want to have visibility into
what is going on in my complex system. Yeah.
So, as we talk about these stochastic agents,
it's it's very hard when agents are calling agents
and you're like, "What the heck's happening?" And
I think that's really where you're focused in on
is um really driving that observability into these
agentic and human flows all together and how do
I do this in a highly auditable environment. So,
that's it's pretty cool. So, I know we got a
demo today to look at. Do we want to jump right
in the demo? Uh let's do it. All right. Sweet.
So here I have um an enterprisegrade application
uh monitoring Onyx Incorporated. Um and as
you can see there's many different aspects and
layers to this application. Um and so what I
first want to do is just peek open behind the
scenes and see the complexity um of my workflow.
Um you can see the many layers of workshop apps.
You can see the many layers of language models
being used. AP logic functions myon ontology
um all powering this application and it's it's
you want to ask first like um how can I get into a
specific invocation of this workflow and see like
under the covers what exactly is going on and so
I I can search for a specific uh function here
I can go to let's do Titan inventory relocation
model and let me just pop on open the run history
uh for this function I can see okay this is being
called by an automation um I can go down and
see exactly when these invocations are happening
um I can see the run times and then I can go
into a specific invocation and and see an actual
uh trace for uh the function invocation and
so here I can see the request being made
um specific details in terms of the request status
the result the arguments uh being made in this
function invocation um my specific interactions
with the ontology that I'm using um and then I can
hop on over um and and see any log lines created
by either uh the high trust services orchestrating
uh my workflows or the uh code that I'm writing
um within Foundry. I think this is this is like
a great example of things going well. Uh there's
also going to be times when my functions are not
working as that like as expected. And so here's
an example of a Titan vision image prop function
that is being used to orchestrate some of these
workflows. And I'm I'm seeing failures. I can
go in to these log details um see the failures
happening uh click in investigate and and get
like very granular um information on okay this
was a permission denied error uh interacting
with my language models and get really granular
information right to me um and I can action on it,
fix this and build on top of that. Um and so the
the vision here is um in this complex workflow,
how can I go and search for certain executables,
see their run histories, see traces of these
executions and then see logs associated with and
kind of dig in to what is going on with my complex
system. Yeah. So you have like a massive complex
application, ton of ontology objects, AI agents
running all over the place, like humans calling
functions, like all of it. And so now whether
I want to investigate it or I want to there's
a problem or an error, like it's not just how
they connect together in the functions, it's like
the individual invocations are in here. So like I
think that's the important piece is to be able to
get down to the individ individual like auditable
logs and calls about who did it from where when
did they do it right? I think that's a huge deal.
Yeah, I totally agree. Um and you're not always
going to have just one simple function uh calling
um the ontology. There could be like a complex
chain of an automate calling an action calling
five different functions. Um, and you're going
to want to see the kind of crosscutting nature
of this observability and and and see how it goes
through the seams. Um, and how Foundry kind of
integrates all that for you. Yeah. And I think
that's the it's part of the value chain here is
when you're developing and and like working on new
workflows or I introduced a new model, how is that
actually functioning? So, as things are living and
breathing over time, being able to actually have a
view in at the granular level to understand what's
going on, I think is pretty important. Yep. And
from there we can go on over to let's say I want
to investigate my uh AAP logic functions and and
I know they interact with uh a bunch of different
models and and here I can see exactly like the
model usage done by these specific um AAP logic
functions get the token count um and see the cost
um and so it's not only showing you the granular
logs and the traces but giving you metrics on top
of your workflows to see like where your resources
are being spent um is also very important here.
Yeah, that's pretty neat, especially when trying
to understand uh the LM usage across workflows.
This is huge. Let's also dig back into um a
specific AAP logic function um getting triggered
by an automation. So we can go into uh the
details, see the trace, see that it's a AAP logic
effect executing via automate, get the granular uh
tags on what exactly the monitor like the monitor
ID that was triggered, the version, the RID, and
then go specifically down um into granular spans
over the AIP logic function. You can see it was
an anttology edit. Um, and so this was writing
back into myontology and then go all the way down
into the model being called, uh, the duration. Uh,
see the action being executed. Um, and then pop
on over and and see token usage, see the requests
being made to my language model and go deep into
this automated system and get granular visibility
that you need as a builder. Yeah, that's pretty
cool. That that stack trace view is killer to be
able to kind of understand the order of operations
of these agentic flows. Um cuz you know sometimes
they'll loop around. I call the model a bunch of
times to reason across something. But having the
visibility here to be able to understand you know
the order of execution and what it's calling and
get to that level of like actually I want to go
see this actual like call that's uh that's pretty
cool to be able to debug things here. I definitely
agree. Um and only getting started in terms of the
amount of resources that we'll be emitting into
this view and the telemetry getting emitted. Um
and so it's it's really exciting. Yeah. Yeah, and
I think that the, you know, this is one of the
things like this, this type of observability is
key to really scale this. It's like it's nuanced
if you do it on one agent here, but let's say you
have 70 or 100 agents working across a workflow,
like how do you debug those things? Um, when it
gets big like that, I think that is where this is
absolutely crucial to be able to understand what's
going on 100%. Um, and not only are we Foundry
going to be an AIP going to be emitting a lot of
telemetry automatically for you, uh, but there's
also a lot of investment in allowing builders
to customize the telemetry they are emitting,
um, and using open and standard libraries to emit
that telemetry. And so that's something I'd love
to talk about next. Yeah, let's let's take a look
at that. Sweet. So, uh, here's an example of a
TypeScript v2 function uh, called high priority
tickets. Um, and as you can see, I went over
uh into my libraries and I installed the open
telemetry API um along with the uh API logs
uh libraries and these have millions of installs
on npm and used um vastly across the developer
TypeScript community. Um, and here I can get
my tracer and I can start a custom span. I'm
calling my AIP logic function which um here I'm
filtering for open support tickets uh which is
a very standard type of uh query um if I want to
learn more about my enterprise and and then I'm
asking my AIP logic function to go and summarize
uh the most important ones and kind of and give
me like a response as um a user like what are the
most important tickets for uh me to prioritize.
And so if we go on over um um I have all my
run history uh for my high priority tickets
function. I can go into the log details and I can
see my custom spans getting emitted. Um a nice
benefit of TSV2 is we um auto instrument every
outbound network request. So here we can see um us
interacting with the API gateway um instrumented
directly for us. And so it's the mix of custom
spans from me as a developer along with the auto
instrumentation that AIP provides out of the box
um that we're really hoping will um encourage
builders to have a lot more visibility and um
and trust in their systems. Yeah. And especially
in a heterogeneous kind of enterprise architecture
to be able to have these logs next to the rest
of your stuff is is pretty useful or alerting
or other things that you're wanting to have. So
that's very cool that we can customize all that.
I want to give massive shout out to the AP logic
team. They are building um very amazing debugger
views in their product. And so if we want to take
a look at this preview run um we can see in real
time uh traces getting emitted seeing in real
time a debugger um and if I can see the granular
real-time steps of my business logic I just have
much more confidence and visibility into these
systems and um it's amazing work here um and the
broader vision of getting telemetry across AIP and
into users hands as fast and easily as possible
is the major focus. of um the broader group. Yeah,
this is neat. This is probably one of
my favorite things to demo, especially a
really complex logic function. This one's pretty
simple here, but like showing like a very complex
uh chain of thought reasoning in the stack trace
happening in real time, being able to debug,
understand where the long pole is. Um it's cool.
Like it's super helpful as you're building these
things of trying to debug what model, how am I
tweaking the prompt, what's happening. There's so
many different uh variables. So to be able to see
it kind of in that view is like really neat. Yeah,
I I couldn't agree more. So now taking a look at
maybe a more complex workflow. Um I have a car
recommendation automation. Um where I'm receiving
a new car and I want to process it. Um you can
see five or six different actions being executed
going into uh four or five different functions.
can see the user code, the function calls all the
way down to my models. And if we want to see like
what's actually being called from these models,
we we can see like you are an assistant meant
to summarize car maintenance reports and predict
a likelihood of reoccurrence. Um, and we and we
can see exactly the data that was sent to our
LLMs and and audit this work. And we can also
integrate this with our custom logging, seeing
what recommendations we're making for our unique
ids, seeing all the LLM requests, the token
usage, the successful executions, going back to
our trace view and seeing where the time is being
spent. Um, and forward looking, seeing how we can
optimize this complex chain of invocations. Yeah.
So like this is to just kind of take it up a level
like thinking about it as a business process
flow whether it's like order to cash I get an
order in as a manufacturer and I have to figure
out do I have enough inventory do I have enough
raw materials and production capacity that entire
business process flow you could actually look at
it this way and understand through here the entire
flow of how that actual process is happening with
logs associated across it and how long it takes
not only at a high level uh like we have tools
like machinery to look at more of kind of the
the the flow of that, but it's this is at the
actual instance of an object being created, which
is pretty wild to think about like, oh, I have a
trouble order. I want to go diagnose something.
You could literally see every single detail about
the entire thing in one one place. And on top
of that uh when I write back to my system and
I want to automate further, I get a full history
of this whole chain and I can get insight not from
just today but yesterday and last week and get a
more holistic understanding of the system. Yeah,
cuz normally like this would be across a ton of
different systems. Sometimes you try to throw
it in some sort of log aggregator and then query
across it and that's not business friendly or in
like trying to figure out what is this doing or
I'm going to join a bunch of tables together to
try to understand the business process. But here
having all of that lineage tracked as the process
is actually happening with the nitty-gritty
details like it's that's pretty neat. All right,
that's that's pretty cool. There's a lot there to
be able to like view into the system of systems
you're building. So how are our customers using
this? Sure. So one example is Gallatin AI. They
build very complex ODK third party application
on top of Foundry. Um and in production they were
able to get visibility into all their complex um
ontology loading um and function calls and action
calls and were able to optimize a lot of their
workflows once they had the observability into
the system. um and in instead of needing to kind
of guess uh they were able to see with real data,
real telemetry where they needed to improve their
system um we were able to help them do that and so
that was very exciting. Um, additionally, a second
part of this work is we want to provide an amazing
inplatform experience, but we also want to let
power builders export their logs to streaming data
sets, third-party systems. And so, it's been very
exciting to see a lot of for deployed engineers
use the streaming data set to build very complex
um analytical uh workshops and other monitoring
views on on top of this data. Um, and that kind of
twofold approach has been really exciting. That's
pretty neat. So you're saying I have I'm emitting
my logs to a stream and I'm able to take that
stream and ontologize it and build apps on top of
the ontology of the monitoring and alerting of my
other apps I built that are maybe consumerf facing
or customerf facing. Exactly. And so you can also
write you write back to your ontology in terms of
a connected enterprise but then you also want the
telemetry of your systems that you're using this
um back into your ontology. And so it's almost
like a second right back um to get the feedback
loop spinning. Yeah. Uh that's pretty cool cuz I
I could totally see how then you could even take
that a next step further and use AFTTE and start
to actually look at the code behind some of these
alerts and other things. There could be a whole a
whole virtuous loop here now that you have open
access to all the the logs. That's pretty cool.
So what do you see kind of coming? Like what are
you working on that's maybe a couple months out
that uh would be fun to share? Yeah. So I would
say the first thing I'm most excited about is in
platform metrics and monitoring for these AIP
workflows. Um I have my actions, my functions,
my automates. I want to get paged and alerted
when things go south. Um and I want to have
confidence that I have a fully monitored system.
Um and I'm I'm really excited for the investments
and and the metrics and um telemetry getting
emitted um and the integrations with monitoring
um happening. Additionally, um I'm very excited
about our push to make the streaming data set
an otelkon compliant uh format that uh power
builders can export to a third party systems
and use how they like. We want amazing defaults.
We want a great inplatform experience, but we also
want to be the home of interoperability and we
want power builders to be able to do what they
want with their telemetry. And then lastly,
I would say I'm really excited that we have
um an AIP uh telemetry kind of data store now
across different platforms, products, teams um all
emitting to a central place. And now the question
is how do we get it into users hands as easily as
possible across the platform? I have an error.
How do I have a one-click way to see my trace,
see my logs? And it's really exciting to see
all like the developers kind of hone in and come
um wanting to work on this um now that it's
finally real. Uh which is really exciting. It's
in workflow builder. It's going to be more places
very soon. And that is what I'm I'm very excited
about. Yeah, that'll be neat to be able to just
one click and see kind of everywhere it is just
like we do with data, but now we're talking about
the not only the data, the logic and the actions,
the ontology objects, all these different
components. So, I love that we've expanded beyond
just the data piece to really get these, you know,
the observability across everything. So, awesome.
Well, thanks Bennett for joining me today. I
really appreciate the time. Thanks for having me.